The correct answer is it will stay as it is.
One way of seeing this is the following--the central compartment loses
temperature to the left and gains temperature from the right if you will.
The amount of gain and loses proportional to the difference in temperature,
but to the left and to the right, the difference in temperature is the same,
so we lose as much as we gain.
The temperature of the central compartment has to stay constant.
Of course, the same is true for the compartment to the left.
We'll just look at one further compartment down the road
and see that this compartment to the left gains as much as its going to lose.
Another way of seeing this behavior is to look at the heat equation.
The partial derivative of the temperature with respect to time
equals thermal diffusivity times the second derivative of temperature.
Now, with respect to x, this is a line of constant slope, which means we have to form the derivative
of this derivative with respect to x, but when the first derivative is constant,
the derivative of this derivative is zero--this line has a slope of zero, so the right hand side
of the heat equation equals zero, which leads us to the statement that there is no change in time.
In reality, of course, we can never have this type of linear gradient going on and on.
The temperature must not shrink below 0 K, but of course in practice, there's some upper limit as well.
So eventually, we will see some changes to that curve
because energy accumulates downstairs and is depleted upstairs.